So as we were building
out our purchase flow.
One of the things which
we became attuned
to is the importance of making
sure people feel comfortable.
Putting their payment information
into the purchase experience.
And so one of the things
which we did learn is that
it's important to offer
multiple different options.
Because different buyers
have different levels of
appreciation of the security as you're
going through the purchase flow.
And so for us that meant being able
to offer both a credit card option or
offering like a PayPal option.
And so,
I think traditionally it's kind of
understood to try to make your purchase
experience as simple as possible.
Like remove all the different options.
But, particularly as you
think about payments,
creating options which give
the sense of security.
Was pretty important as we
built out this experience.